i'm now a mom and i just it's i just
have so much more empathy and compassion
and i also understand why she drinks
every day at five
well as you can see it's like me he
loves to be naked so when we took our
photo i like throw something over him
i'm like okay
oh yeah he was a big baby big big big
baby
and um so when i got pregnant with my
daughter
um i got a epidural oh amen
[Music]
gal you have two daughters uh what do
they think of their mom being wonder
woman
is there pressure with that um you know
what it's so funny i
literally asked alma last night because
i've been
asked this question all the time and i
just say they're proud of me they're
proud of me
so i just figured i'm gonna ask her so
last night i asked her how do you feel
about me portraying wonder woman
and she gave me the sweetest answer she
said i'm very happy about it
it can be hard sometimes because when
you and patty shoot the movie
you work all the time and and we miss
you but i'm growing out of it because
i'm getting used to it from one movie to
the other
but i'm very very proud of that and it's
super fun that you're
portraying wonder woman so that's like
the legit answer
from alma uh first of all you just it
made every mom
in the world feel good because my
daughter is six and she gives me
such crap for every time i go to work
she's like i don't understand why
and i'm like i'm here like every morning
every night like normal parents but like
she gets they they don't understand it
all the time especially in the
entertainment industry our hours are so
different and
that's it just made me feel good because
i'm always having this battle with like
mommy's here all the time i'm like
anyway so it's good to know that wonder
woman is getting kicked in the
knee with you no you're taking amazing
you're doing amazing
kelly and you're not alone we all suffer
from the same thing and it's in a way
it's a good problem to have because it
means that we have conscious
and we think about our children and we
want to be with them and we care about
them the most
but at the end of the day it's all also
so important
to you know get lead by example and
be a good role model for them yeah and
um and show them what this is nothing
your woman looks like
[Music]
as a woman that loves to be busy myself
um how do you find balance
especially with a family involved in
that as well well you know i think i
feel like i'm just like you're saying
every american woman who's working and
trying to take care of a family
and yeah i love my teaching job and then
i have everything in
all the issues that i'm working on in
the white house so
it's like every other american woman
woman and i think
you know moms have had it i mean they
were struggling before
the pandemic and i think it's just
really exacerbated
everything that moms have to handle and
now they're helping their kids online
and
um and by the way haven't our teachers
been
so amazing oh i just love my god i love
our kids
shout out to my kids school because it's
it's a hard thing because teaching is a
i mean you go to school to learn how to
be a great teacher and it is a gift
innately given i think not everyone is
great at teaching
so it's an incredible thing that i think
people now realize i've been shouting it
for years just because i have a
spotlight and my mom is a teacher
well and it's it's really important and
i think people are just now
unfortunately a silver lining from this
whole situation has been i agree
realizing how hard it is to be a teacher
people are like
oh i have to wrangle my three kids i'm
like teachers have to wrangle like 25 to
30.
i'm like i'm like yeah it's a hard job
and i
i love that one time you spoke about you
know in in your sessions because you do
a lot of resume
right everybody's doing resume and
you're sitting there teaching your class
and you have mothers that have their
kids like crawling on them or their
babies and they have nowhere to put
their yeah it's a hard
thing and so that's why you say like
covet it'd be nice if we figured this
out because it was already hard enough
to begin with it was already hard enough
you know i see from my students i mean
they're
you know and i'm the one thing i have to
say is
um there is hope there is hope coming i
mean we're
we're going to do better with child care
we're going to get jobs we're going to
get our kids back in schools
we're going to do better with food
insecurity i mean there is hope so
that's why i think
i hear that from so many people who are
saying jill we now feel like we can
sort of breathe a little bit you know we
see the light at the end of the tunnel
and i think that's so
important for all americans i agree we
need that i cling to it sometimes
as a parent
how has being a mama changed your
relationship with your mom because i
agree with you like my mom
she was a single mom for a lot of my
like you know um developmental years
with me and my brother and sister around
so it's just us so it was
really interesting to see that dynamic
and now i'm
a single mom with my with my two and
it's it's an interesting thing
to to to kind of a different vantage
point a different perspective looking
back at her life and being like
oh that was hard that must have been
hard oh totally and i
i think the minute i got pregnant i had
so much empathy and compassion for my
mom and just so much guilt too
for everything i put her through or my
attitude and my mom is also my manager
so sometimes those lines get blurred if
i'm
if we're having an argument about
something business related
we know how to separate it but if
someone's probably watching us they're
like oh my goodness
like how i speak to her is crazy but now
i think i have a
totally different um way of just even
talking with my mother and receiving
what she has to say to me even if it's
from a workplace
because i'm now a mom and i just it's
i just have so much more empathy and
compassion and i also understand why she
drinks every day at five
[Laughter]
or sometimes before five no judgment
[Music]
well michelle i'd ask how quarantine has
been but you have twin toddlers at home
so basically
you need wine and a nanny
oh there's hazel and otis i love them so
much this has been
a joyful marathon i just wish i had
clean spoons at some point in the day i
mean i've never talked to a dishwasher
so often but here we are oh my gosh i
know the cleaning is insane
so are you like me um your only alone
time is maybe in the bathroom
oh it's my favorite i just sit on the
toilet and answer
emails
it's very quiet in there i've never
enjoyed tile and porcelain so much
it is funny though because i look at
myself i'm sitting there on my phone
just trying to get be productive
i don't even take the time to pee i just
have to be doing
something else like while i'm like this
is an issue
for um a society i think but um cheryl
so was it like that with your daughter
uh at my house yeah oh i sit in the
driveway in my car what yeah that's my
that's my time what yeah do you just
listen to music or
yes yes i listen to music i
talk on the phone it's the only place
yeah
the only place i have any privacy so if
i want to talk about
anybody in my house i have to sit in the
car to do it oh my god
i know i love doing a good therapy
session on the phone in the car because
then no one in the house can hear what
you're saying about
them oh man i should worry about that
more
yeah i don't i don't i just i might on
speaker phone i'm like
let him hear it like you're gonna hear
it eventually i'm open
[Music]
[Applause]
my question to you is have you ever said
something to your kid
that you later wish that you hadn't
because they repeated it
and then how do you get your kids to
understand that sometimes you know
things that
are said in the household need to stay
in the household
oh god when you know that answer like
let us know like i'm like
i i'm going to be honest i told my i
just thought of this i thought i don't
really have anything for that and then
i my daughter became obsessed when she
was like four years old about
where she came from and i was like
well i was like you were and then she
started being nervous about
death like and i was like what is
happening like she was
at four like i feel like that didn't
happen like 10 for me but whatever
but anyway she's advanced and she was
talking about death and all these things
and i wanted to feel
like good about like not dying or like
anything like that and then also like
well you are a part of mommy and then
you know so you'll always have me so
even if mommy dies like i'm you were a
part of me you were in mommy's tummy
actually
so like you were always a part of me and
like so that'll never go away you're
from my body so like you carry mommy on
so
you know in a sense mommy will never die
with you because i'm a part of you
and then she took that as in any woman
in the world regardless if you have a
stomach or not walks up to and goes do
you have a baby in there
oh yeah and just doesn't matter
who it is and just is very excited that
don't worry
if you die she's still gonna carry you
on
like it's still like and it's like you
missed the we shouldn't
tell people that they're pregnant that's
another one you should yeah that
happened
a lot you know what my four-year-old was
obsessed with death both of our kids
were obsessed with death and they
when you're trying to explain it you got
to simplify it you know because it's too
much for them to handle so
we had to explain that grandpa greg had
died and was no longer with us and then
they were like why
and we're like because he eat too many
cheeseburgers
because you can't if you go down the
list of ailments he had it'd
be there they'd be lose focus so then
like every time we go somewhere they
call him dead grandpa greg
and we feel like that's oh my god
and you know we're too head-cramped
it's accurate it's accurate
oh my gosh my kids know that um there's
no baby in here
but they'll come when i'm like wearing
my relaxing pants you know my
loose evening pants and go there's a
baby in there
oh my god it's a food baby first of all
can we talk that you just said loose
relax what did you call them your loose
comfy pants
i loved my loose evening pen i love you
your house is fancy yeah she has a very
fancy name for him yeah
like my lululemons that i don't do yoga
in
all right so quarantine has been hard on
moms
um has there been one moment that stood
out for you while working from home
probably specifically
yeah well i mean i'm sure you've had it
too where
we were doing the show and then all of a
sudden you would hear the little foot
prints the little foot sounds of
children that would sneak in and there
was one particular moment
where mila and poppy were in a major
fight over barbies
and then cleaning up the barbies in
particular and all of a sudden mila's
over my shoulder like poppy's so mean
you know and i'm on television
so there was no way to really um
negotiate i was like we will talk about
this in a minute mila but she just stood
there
like a little mermaid over my shoulder
the entire time
that's actually amazing my daughter
busted on her
we have this like long little hallway
and she was on this little scooter and
she just
busted right in the middle of me
interviewing so and then i i totally got
up
i just got my mine wasn't live like
yours but i i just got up from the
interview and i was like oh my god and
it was just
an innate reaction and then i was i came
back on and i was like i'm so sorry i
just left
but it happens when you're working from
home but having two daughters
are you getting karmic payback from when
you were little you and your sister
i mean i think so but i have you know
they haven't hit the teenage years yet
i think it's gonna get rough around 15
or 16.
what was the most meaningful valentine's
card you ever received was it like from
your kids
mine is for my kids but oh i mean i
wanna
yeah anything that they have written or
drawn ever of all time a card from them
with some you know i passed a glue to it
and i'm like in tears
um but my my favorite one was from my
son
um my daughter when she was born i asked
my son
what it felt like to hold her for the
first time and he said
impossible it was like a dream my heart
cracked open into tiny little wood chips
and then came back together like eggs
and bacon
and so that valentine's day he drew me a
card that had eggs and bacon inside this
heart and i just
was obviously in pieces wait did he say
how old was he when he said that
he was six oh my gosh he should get into
poetry that was really beautiful
that was the cinnamon is so sweet so
what
they just go together what is so they do
i love eggs making um
so wait what what have your children
taught you about life because i mean for
me it's
patience has been a big thing for me so
still working on it actually sarah but
what about you
definitely that especially in a pandemic
yeah um a lot of patience and then i
think just to really be in the moment
because obviously there's that's the
only place they can be and know to be
and i think because i have such a big
age gap between
my kids who are four and 11 um
you know have the benefit of seeing how
fast it goes by with the first one so
if you're not in the moment i mean you
just you miss it it just goes like that
i honestly it terrifies me because
everybody always says that like oh it
goes by so fast so like
i but i go the extreme other way and i'm
like let's do legos let's paint let's do
everything every day together because
this moment is all you're not going to
want me around forever and so i just
we do so much at my house because i
don't want to miss any and they get so
big
and you're like stop growing but grow
whatever
[Music]
what do your kids think about the book
are they excited about it like my
my girl didn't get it for a while that
it was named after her like i have one
and she didn't get it for a while now
she thinks it's super cool
but what do your kids think oh they
didn't get it either like you get to the
end of the book and then you'd be like
mommy why are you in the book why is
your picture yeah i mean
they didn't yes exactly the same thing
didn't get it at all
um and then sometimes he'll be milo will
be literally like
hold my face and he'll do this thing
where he holds it and gives me a big
smooch and he goes
mom that was a movie star kiss it's so
lovely i love this book
and then other times he because he's big
obviously because he's a four-year-old
it's slightly
jekyll and hyde and you never really
know what you're going to get
right yeah amen and so
uh the one night he says to me mom um
he's a bit like a teenager at this point
mum yeah you'll book it so i can do
anything
i said yes milo you can if you put your
if you put your minds or something and
you find something you love and you want
to work hard you can do
anything you want to do and he's like
well that's not true is it
i don't know uh well uh well
what do you mean he says well that's not
true because what i want to do
is i want to take a koala home from the
zoo bring it here and keep it as a pet i
can't
do that it's very literal
and through my head i'm going cat
dealies kid kidnapped koala
and killed it from doing you know
oh no no no no no no no no you can't do
that you can't see that
i said but what you can do and you know
in those and i'm sure we've all had
those moments where
you know when they ask you something and
your brain is like
racing trying to find the right answer
you can always hear your brain work and
it's like
[Music]
it's almost like a drum roll for when
you come up with the answer
and you're going as fast as you can and
i said no molly you absolutely can't do
that i said but what you can do
is if you go to school and you study
really hard
and maybe you might study something
called biology and then you can
study something called zoology and go to
university then
you could be in charge of all the koalas
at the zoo
or you could even travel to the other
side of the planet which is as far as
you can get to australia which is where
koalas come from
and you could go to a sanctuary and you
could help koalas who don't have a mom
and dad
would be the cancer and i just
and i left it like that i was in my head
i was like high-fiving myself and all
the rest of it he just looked at me like
that
he's like not the same all right mom all
right
i guess i'll accept that answer
but you you've actually you've delivered
babies on the show so
what what were the births of your own
kids like were they intense
i was so ready to get mine out just get
out get out get out
yes oh yes well uh my son was huge
uh he was human humongous and um
i feel like the hippies lied to me
because i
i was watching these documentaries about
these water births
and they were all you know doing this
like uh they were just i was like wow
this i can do that
i can do that i'm gonna do a water birth
so
i i go to this hospital where they
actually allow water births in the
hospital
but um my water breaks at five in the
morning
pop i literally felt it break i was like
oh
my water broke then the labor just
started coming really fast
and so i didn't have time to stop like
my husband's like watch tv
it'll be hours it's your first baby we
don't know so
no no no so we're driving and i'm like
in
whatever transition in the car i think
um by the time i get to the hospital i'm
nine centimeters and so i push for
two hours out of the birthing tub
um screaming bloody murder
and i was like he's stuck he's stuck i
kept waiting for somebody to be like
oh we have to take him out of you via
cesarean emergency c-section and i was
like
nobody's coming and i'm still pushing
and then they get the tub set up and it
didn't really seem to make a difference
unfortunately um and
i finally got him out and he was like
nine pounds and so
oh yeah he was a big baby big big big
baby
and um so when i got pregnant with my
daughter
um i got a epidural oh amen
oh wow i didn't oh it did and it was a
beautiful experience
like magical because and i should have
listened to my two friends
one of two of my best friends had babies
and they were like girl get the epidural
don't be stupid
if you're gonna take tylenol or motrin
for a headache
you're gonna need the good drugs and
it was a beautiful experience with her i
pushed her out in 20 minutes and
she was the glorious happy baby and
dude i'll tell you what oh yeah it i had
friends tell me as well there were there
are several different ideas of what you
know should happen over your birth
and i was like if god intended for me to
not have drugs
and not have help getting this out then
he wouldn't have had me born in 1982
i am gonna take what do you what can you
put in here to make it less
hurtful i was like give me everything
the baby will be
fine i was like does it make you want to
just pop some children out
is that just like birth control what
just happened
thank you
well how about your daughter she's 16
now is she adventurous
she's incredibly adventurous i mean it's
interesting she's like a great mix of
uh pragmatic and adventurous like she
she loves to kind of
explore life outside her comfort zone
but then she's like very logical at the
same time i think it's a good combo
yeah it sounds very balanced i'm going
to work on that the 16 year old seems to
be nailing it
well speaking of kids i saw this photo
that you posted
you said little dude in the back
pretending he didn't eat half my sando
they don't ever ask my kids just walk up
and take my stuff
does that happen all the time to you yes
you know what's so funny i remember
actually before i had kids i have a
cousin
who uh first cousin i'm really close to
her name's lisey and i remember hers
telling me
she's like having kids is the best thing
in the world but it's a totally
different game she's like i mean you
make yourself a whole sandwich and then
they just like take it
and you don't even care you just give
them the sandwich but
i've always remembered that so yeah i
mean they'll they definitely
um i think it's good when kids feel like
that
level of healthy entitlement for a
parent and like what you're supposed to
provide for them you know
yeah well i think a healthy dose of
entitlement not too much
yeah so you're true yeah do your kids
like to tease you
oh my god constantly constantly
especially i mean we're we're out of it
now but i went through a phase
with my daughter where i wasn't allowed
to like hum
dance move like i was mortifying her on
every level
um she makes fun of me more than my son
does my son is
he's like he's he's really his humor is
different
but she just like yeah she's always
making fun of me oh my god my daughter's
already doing
that at the age of six so i can't it's
been great foreshadowing for what's to
come
[Music]
how have you been doing um with
explaining everything to your kids this
year it has been hard for me
it it it is hard because i don't want
them to like stress out the way
i stress out and the adults but i don't
also want to
shelter them so much that they're like i
don't i didn't know there was a pandemic
yeah
and i also try to make it fun of like
this is the story that you're gonna
tell your grandchildren and you know we
walk to school so we leave the front
door and come around the side and we
like
walk to school
and we sing a little like song that's
the thing going somewhere though my
daughter literally
like was in tears one day with me and
was just like i just can we just go
somewhere and eat or do any like
you get to go to work and and remy my
son got to go to school and her school
hadn't allowed in person yet and she was
just in tears she was like
i just want to go somewhere and i was
like oh my god because i've been going
somewhere every day just
for work and it's it's so hard it is on
the kids
you mentioned you guys were pregnant the
last time that we
saw how are your babies oh so so so
are you doing better than with the fake
babies yeah yeah
oh yeah oh my gosh oh my gosh
so adorable aren't they cute they're so
i just
mine matteo who's on the right he's just
i mean he's still well
as you can see it's like me he loves to
be naked so when we took that photo i'd
like throw something over him i'm like
okay
that's my little baby but he's just i
get peed on all the time
oh and artem's always like put clothes
on him i'm like just put a towel down
like he needs to be free but that's the
one thing with boys
is i wasn't even not just boys my mother
will tell you
i you couldn't keep clothes on me oh
really yep
take them off yeah but well how's that
so brie how's your daughter doing as a
big sis so she's doing really good
but you know you have kids you get it
she turned three she's a three major
so she likes to be right there's nothing
does she get a little jealous
gets a little just and she's starting to
tell me off a little bit
oh my mind's my little my six-year-old
now is a 16 year old at times
isn't it crazy yeah i'm like who do you
think you are
that's what i say mine will go don't
talk to me like that and i'm like
no you don't talk to me like that it's
crazy and then i'm like are you
mirror imaging is that is that what i
know my mom said that
my mom goes bree you know where she
heard that from i'm like i don't say
that
i don't say that i'm so classy
that's what i say too oh man it's they
can get crazy but the jealousy thing can
get crazy of attention
every time i breastfeed it's when i get
told off oh my gosh yeah
well don't well hang in there
did you take time off after your kids
like i feel like i didn't take enough
with
my first child and my second took a
little bit more my first one i went
right in and i maybe shouldn't have
i i took um i took time off with both of
them a little bit again probably not
enough
um but with with my daughter for sure
not enough because i
i was i don't know i was like really
hyper aware
of letting people know that just because
i had a kid it didn't mean that i
couldn't be the same person that i was
before that i could go back to work
right like i really just
wanted to please them in that way and
let them know that yeah and so i went to
um
i went to a meeting uh at the beverly
hills hotel with my agent like
way too soon afterwards to just sort of
say like yeah let's find something you
know and get back to work even though
inside i was like i don't even know what
day it is and i'm crying all the time
um yeah but i so i got there and i put
on this like
silk jumpsuit and i'm i'm not back
at all to like you know pre-baby
whatever i'm still not back to pre-baby
whatever to truth be told but anyway
um so i'm not like ready but i you know
look nice and i go
and for whatever reason in my brain i
thought that breast
milk was kind of like cell service
and like if you're out of the area
you know it's not gonna happen oh no and
so
i didn't have breast pads like i hadn't
left my house yet so i didn't know that
like you should do the whole
anyway so i go and i'm in this meeting
and all of a sudden like in this very
sort of emotional plea for people to
understand that i am
so cool i'm like just have a baby now
and heading back to work
um i start leaking breast milk in a silk
jumpsuit in a restaurant
oh and i can see them looking like oh
um what's happening there um and nobody
says anything so i like take a menu and
i
you know i hide and then it starts
happening with the other one
so i text my friend who had driven with
me and i'm like i need you to go to the
gift shop
and find whatever they have i don't care
if it's a bathrobe like
you need to come to this restaurant with
some things
so i can walk out of here with my
dignity i'm gonna make it a look and i'm
getting out of here
i have a situation so he comes
to the to the restaurant and it's like
115 degrees outside
i am hormonal and leaking two like
baloney sized stains
on this jumpsuit in the beverly hills
it's not good
and he comes it's awesome
he comes with this cashmere scarf and
he's like here drink this up so i'm like
you know i drape it over the front and i
oh i
walked out of that restaurant like so i
walk out
and i get in the car and i'm like hey so
um
why this cashmere scarf because it's the
only thing that happened because by the
way don't be mad
it was six hundred dollars oh
and i'm like what i was like
i was like i would have taken a napkin i
was like a napkin would have been like
so i have this 600 scarf that i
literally wear anytime it drops like
below 70 degrees and i am wearing this
thing for the next 25 years of my life
oh my gosh 600 for a scarf
but i got out of there with my dignity
so it worked out
well bendy also congratulations on the
baby so how are you feeling
oh thank you so incredibly excited
little baby wildlife warrior will be
here in just a few months and
we are so happy she is now
about the same size as a platypus
um we can't i feel weird comparing her
to fruits and vegetables and things so
we've been comparing her to animals
and um yes she's our little platypus at
the moment and it's
very cute she's she's busy though my
goodness
all i do is get kicked i don't think she
ever sleeps so i think we're gonna have
our hands full she's ready to take oh
yeah we're at the stage now where we're
starting to see
feet and hands come through bendy's
belly it is the coolest thing
we're so excited it always it tripped me
out because i remember
i don't know what it was if i felt like
i was on like alien the movie like when
you could things were moving out of
something
and i was like i was like i always i
never was that girl that was like oh i
was like oh my god
you're gonna love them and they will be
a handful so you watch out
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever